Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here, and today
I wanna talk about reading, how to use
reading to increase your vocabulary.
Um, you know, I, I always stress
the importance of varying our
activities in language learning.
I talked a bit about Atomic Habits
and developing good, sort of, learning
habits that keep you going, uh,
without necessarily always worrying
about the end of the road, you
know, fluency, whatever that might.
So we have to have good habits.
We have to vary the kind of activity
we do and different activities help
us in different ways, obviously.
So if you're in a conversation
group, you're practicing using
the words that you already know.
Probably you're practicing using
a small subset of the words that
you understand, because our active
vocabulary is always gonna be
smaller than our passive vocabulary.
But at least if you have good
listening comprehension, you understand
what other people are saying.
When we are listening here, again, we can
only understand the words that we know.
So listening is a way of reinforcing
your passive vocabulary, improving
your comprehension, all of which
is very good, good things to do.
In fact, I spend more time listening
than any other activity, 'cause
it's the easiest thing to do.
I can do it anytime, anywhere, but reading
is where we can acquire new vocabulary.
And I'm gonna talk a bit about extensive
reading versus intensive reading and
how it helps us acquire new words.
So in a way, the ultimate
experience in extensive reading
is to read a book, a paper book.
You have no distractions.
You can't go anywhere.
You're there with the
book, words you don't know.
You just let them go by you and you're
experiencing reading the language,
your're experiencing, converting,
you know, various characters on
a piece of paper into meaning.
Very valuable.
I've always, you know, when I
reach the stage where I can read a
novel in a language I'm learning,
I have reached a major milestone.
And I very often hear people say, well,
you know, uh, I can read well, but
uh, you know, I can't, uh, understand
when I hear people speaking or I
have trouble using the language.
And then I say to those people, do...
have you read a novel in the
language you're learning?
And very often the answer is no.
I mean, you have to get to the point
where you can read novels and read widely.
Not just newspaper articles, but
you know, a book, uh, doesn't
have to be a novel, by the way.
It can be a non-fiction for that matter.
So that's extensive reading on paper.
However, again, we have to get to
that stage because if there's too
many words that you don't know, then
reading in a, you know, away from the
computer is not a pleasant experience.
So that's where reading online with an
online dictionary, and in particular
the way we do things at LingQ, can
help you acquire the vocabulary,
pass the vocabulary so that you
can eventually achieve the ultimate
experience in reading, which is to
grab a book and just read that book.
So I consider reading online, uh,
looking words up, saving words.
That sort of call it LingQ reading
experience is like mining the
language, mining for gold, mining
for minerals, mining for vocabulary,
bringing that vocabulary in.
Initially it's in there somewhere.
You can't retrieve it.
You see that word again in a different
context or many different contexts.
Slowly, it becomes part of your passive
vocabulary, and eventually over time,
some of that vocabulary will become
active vocabulary that you can use.
So extensive reading, which is by
the way, something that Stephen
Krashen constantly promotes.
There's all kinds of experience
which shows, even if an, if
we're not consciously looking up
words, if we are reading widely,
extensively, we're getting more and
more familiarity with the language.
Eventually some of that vocabulary is
naturally going to become known to us as
passive vocabulary be simply because we've
seen it in so many different contexts
that we get a, a, a sense of the meaning.
I prefer to look things up because
I can have a, an erroneous idea
of what the word means and stay
with that for a long, long time.
If I look it up, I may forget it,
but eventually I'll probably get to
a, a correct understanding of the
scope of meaning of that word sooner
if I have at least some opportunity
to see, you know, uh, a translation
of that word into English or into
another language that I know very well.
But even in terms of reading content,
for example, my, uh, Persian tutor
sent me an e-book and I can import
that e-book, you know, essentially
with one click, uh, into LingQ.
So I've got the whole
e-book socked into LingQ.
Now, unfortunately, I don't have
enough audio for that e-book.
That would be even better because
then I could be reinforcing my
mining activity with, you know,
listening while doing other chores.
I don't have that.
However, This book that I
got, this e-book, it's still
sort of difficult for me.
So, uh, I can go at it again within my
extensive reading of this book, I can
go at it intensively or extensively.
If I go at it sort of extensively, then
I'm on sort of page mode and I just read
through looking up words and so forth.
But I'll show you here how I
can go through this material
intensively in sentence mode
and doing the sentence review.
Now, this is more intensive activity.
It's working with, uh, nuts and bolts.
It's reconstituting the sentence, it's
coming, you know, focusing in on the
vocabulary a bit more, putting the
sentence back together again, which
forces me to think of the structure of the
language, the word order in the language.
And however, this is gonna
slow down my mining activity.
I'm coming across fewer and fewer...
fewer, not fewer and fewer, but fewer new
words because I'm working intensively, so
I always like to combine some intensive
work with some extensive work where I'm
just reading, not worrying about the
words, not trying to focus in on them,
not trying to focus in on the structure.
I'm just reading, and yet
at other times I'm working
intensively, as I will demonstrate.
We have a lot of material in our library.
For example, we see here, I think
that probably has audio in it as well.
But let's say we wanna bring
something in so we can go.
For example, if you Google, uh, ... for
example, uh, you'll get the gutenberg.org
in many cases, and you have a variety
of, um, formats that you can download.
I've already done that.
I tried different formats.
And then if you go to LingQ, and I'm
uh, in French here, so you know, you
can either go up here where the plus
sign is and you'll see import e-book.
You can import lesson as well.
You can also install the LingQ
browser extension, so you can
import things with one click.
But in this case, what we wanna
do is we want to import an e-book.
We can also do it here
where it says import.
So we go to import e-book,
and then we click on it.
And here we can simply drag, uh,
an epub version of this book.
It supports a variety of, um, formats,
pdf, uh, text or whatever mobi.
So you just drag it in there, drop it
in there, and um, we're ready to go.
and I happen to be in sentence mode
right now, but, uh, and I'll go, you
know, uh, I can go in the page view now.
There's a lot of, um, English there
at the beginning, and typically
when I import something, I do it
online for a variety of reasons.
Using the web version, it's easier to
do, but I'm gonna work on it on my iPad.
But one of the advantages of doing it
online on the web version is the, and.
That, uh, I can use keystrokes
to get rid of stuff that I don't
want, like non-target language.
I just go X, X, X, X, X, and it
moves through it very, very quickly.
I've already done that, and so I'm
now going to show you how I would
study a book like this on my iPad.
So, but for those of you wanting to
first of all, find e-books to bring in,
it doesn't have to be from gutenburg.
Uh, you can find, um, via an
e-book and, and bring it in.
Some of them are protected, but you
have to find one that's not protected
and you can import the e-book very,
very quickly as I have shown here.
So we're gonna show you, first of all,
this is the, uh, Persian e-book that,
uh, I was sent by my tutor from Iran.
It's a history of the
Second World War in Persian.
I'm working my way through it, but
that's not what I'm gonna show you.
Not many people are doing Persian,
so I have to get to the language here
and change this to French so that I
can check up on what I just imported.
So if I go into French now, uh, I can see
...and whereas some of these show, you
know, minutes of audio, there's obviously
no audio available here, but I can open it
and I get through all this original stuff
in English, which doesn't interest me.
Eh, I got a one day streak going.
All right, so now I'm now into the text.
We'll just move a little further
along where there are some blue words.
There's not, those are not necessarily
words that I don't know, but
because I don't do French online,
but we can go into sentence view.
So ...okay, so ...okay, work.
Okay, work.
And we might decide you
want that word as well.
... so what happens in sentence mode
now is that whatever words I have
saved here, and I, it could be a
blue word that I now make yellow, it
could be a word that I want to add.
I can now study that.
So, and I get these matching
pairs, which include words
that are not in that sentence.
So ... of course is work, but
if I get wrong, it goes pink.
So start again.
Work  Okay.
Correct.
Now I have to reconstitute this
sentence, so ... I have to find, oh, it's
...
correct.
Okay.
If I want to, I can actually,
you know, say the sentence
and it tells me that I was 90% correct.
I don't know how useful that is, but
it's kind of the thing that's available.
So then I go to the next sentence.
So I could do the same thing again.
So by going through sentence by
sentence and, you know, appear, you
know ... that's good to know ... okay.
... event.
Okay.
We choose event.
So I can now go through this
and do the same thing again.
So by going through it sentence
by sentence, I'm actually doing
this, you know, intensively.
However, I might get tired of doing that.
I just go back to the page view where
it's more of an extensive reading
and I can still look up words,
uh, you know, as I, as I do it.
And personally, I tend to vary
the intensive with the extensive.
So I hope that's helpful and I look
forward to questions, but I just wanna
stress again that reading is a phenomenal
way to increase your vocabulary.
If you aren't yet at a stage where you
can read a book, a paper book, then using
something like LingQ can be quite helpful.
So to summarize, reading is a, is perhaps
the best way to acquire more vocabulary.
It's very efficient.
You're looking things up.
Even if you forget it, you'll see
it again and eventually it becomes
part of your passive vocabulary.
So, but reading can be done extensively or
intensively, and I think it's best to vary
extensive reading with intensive reading.
Maybe you spend more time on extensive
reading, but you should probably be
guided by what you feel like doing.
'causeCif you enjoy the activity
that you're involved in, you're
more likely to stay with it.
You're more likely to learn if
you're enjoying the activity.
So just some thoughts here.
I have spoken about reading before, so
I'll leave you with a couple of videos
that talk about reading, but I think
reading is sort of the, uh, the killer
app for acquiring new vocabulary.
Thank you for listening.
And by the way, if you enjoy
these, Please subscribe.
Click on the bell for notifications.
Bye for now.